he just got into this huge yelling match
and then he brought at this point where
I've mentioned this on the podcast
before he was like you don't remember
that time I told you that he wanted to
be a comedian I'll send you to comedy
College I was like dad what the [ __ ] is
comedy College there's no such thing as
comedy College right and his [ __ ]
dumbass too by the way
he starts looking the [ __ ] up and on on
the computer right and you know what he
pops up he pops up some planning school
no he pops up the theater program at
like [ __ ] Columbia I was like I have
to still [ __ ] get into Columbia so it
was a Columbia yeah yeah I still have to
get into the [ __ ] Ivy League college
you don't just it's a theater class what
the [ __ ] are you talking about and so
you know even then like he was so petty
he didn't want to admit that he was
wrong it was like you were [ __ ] wrong
and when I told him in that conversation
was like could you imagine how much
further I could have been now if I
didn't have to fight for your approval
and fight for for this and this I was
like the only reason why you approved
this is because I started making money
if I didn't make money every time I came
back home to Sacramento you would talk
about how disappointed you are at me I
was like those are just facts cuz I
understand now that it's just she
doesn't want me to struggle like we grew
up really poor so he just sees me going
down this route of being poor it's
personal to him it's like I fail as a
parent because my kids poor so I
understand that and then what what
happened we had a breakthrough moment
which is the first thing he ever told me
about his own life that he in 30 years
I've never heard he goes
while I was 20-something at the time but
he was like okay but I told him I was
like you want a relationship with me and
your older son right I was like we'll
never have that I was like you know why
cuz you don't know how to talk to me
like a human being mm-hm
I'm respect yeah there's no respect like
you still talk to me like like you give
me a you don't talk to me you give me
commands do this do that did you do that
but you never asked you never really
asked how I'm doing you never just call
me to have a conversation with the the
first honest moment he has ever had with
me he goes he goes I can't do that
because I've never done that in my whole
life with you my own parents he knows
when I was younger I had to take care of
your parents because your grandpa [ __ ]
up right so when we were younger we had
we had a lot of stuff your grandpa just
[ __ ] threw away all his money I had
to be an adult real quick
your older sisters moved to a mare
one other person denounced me I don't
have relationships because I can't talk
to P because I've never done it you're
expecting me to do something I've never
done my whole life so now as an adult I
was like if you don't understand that
I'm sixty something [ __ ] years old he
goes you have to learn how to bend your
will and accommodate me because I can't
change he goes I've never ever ever in
my life had a conversation with your
parents who passed away my parents were
passed away we've never had a
conversation like how are you doing
right I can't do it did he ever I was
like damn that's the first moment I was
like oh [ __ ] like he's he's like this
because of what his parents did to him
you know do you say like do you love me
enough to try i what I told him I was
like I said he said like he couldn't do
it I was like yeah right at least he was
honest about it he was I can't do it
right he goes I can't do it and I'm like
oh [ __ ] it's crazy that he liked to have
that conversation haven't know about it
and like suppress it enough and like
really lean in on top of his
relationship with his parents like he's
just taken it as fact and yeah knowing
that he is not in control of his life to
break that whatever that relationship he
had and not apply it to you yeah like
it's man it's weird cuz I I do feel my
mom told me too one day she goes you
should feel really bad for your dad
because he's somebody who desperately
wants to have this tight-knit family but
he doesn't have the tools to do it yeah
he doesn't have the social tools like
you use like you you have to feel bad
for him because everything that he's
doing right now to try to keep the
family together it's the same thing that
he's doing to push you guys away right
and so he doesn't know what to do so
that's what he talks to me so I could
talk to you because that's the closest
that he can get to having a conversation
with her but now is it's getting a lot
better now like the other night I've
been talking to him he's been just being
able to joke about [ __ ] as we talk on
the phone and the funny thing is the
connecting factor that allowed me to
talk to my dad is when I talk [ __ ] about
Mariel
this was like this he goes oh that's a
problem he goes your mom is Muriel times
10 right I'm like telling my mom about
some of the stuff that you know she and
I arguing about it my dad's cracking up
me other sessions not dude you're my
[ __ ] hit in a dumpster it goes Oh
Muriel like close the door remember that
time your mom went into the squash patch
in our backyard and laid in there for
all night and when she woke up she had
70 mosquito bites
so we're bonding over how much I [ __ ]
hate the people that we were in love
with and so that's like our bonding
factor right now and that's that we
found the the little segue look correct
into into us being able to connect on
something because we can't really
connect on a lot of things but what we
can do is connect on how much our
significant others piss us off good yeah
at least you have some angle in what
about you and your dad what's the big
shizz we're still working
[Laughter]
we just man I just tried to like cuz I
know what he's gonna talk about but it's
so superficial that I try to give him
more facts so like he's like I can't
believe you know Trump has 50 60 percent
approval rating like how is that
possible like you're saying like 60% of
Americans really want Trump and I don't
like talking about politics on you know
social media all that [ __ ] but I was
like that you have to understand like
what he said was it's not our problem
and I only think where I read this like
sorry Charlemagne Charlemagne Augusta
this he said it's not our problem it
came from China China created the virus
here let me give you a bag with seaming
this relief package and I'll make it all
good and this is how I'm showing you my
leadership on the on the surface that
looks like leadership that's what you
need and in every single day we've been
seeing Trump we haven't seen anything
from like Biden or Sanders or any other
political figure I mean we've we do know
that they are having these virtual town
meetings and talking about Corona
and this and that but it's not enough to
overcome that amount of times we see
Trump saying some crazy-ass [ __ ] so it
doesn't surprise me that people do think
that Trump is doing a good job even
though you know he's like he's talking
so much crazy [ __ ] yeah how do you not
like he's and you I'm sure you've seen
all those little [ __ ] videos of like
Trump saying this is a hoax this is not
a hoax I knew this was a pandemic you
should have listened to me the beginning
but the beginning said you said this is
a hoax and we got this under control
it's down to zero percent there's no
cases of it and now it's like a hundred
thousand and now dr. Fauci whatever is
on my phone that's my phone oh [ __ ]
that's my phone yeah dr. Fauci oh that
that that doctor was saying like yeah
we're having 200 cases of the corona and
in the coming week so like my dad just
takes the Tibbets he can't expound on
that at all
sounds like I have to like fill him in
and be like oh okay yeah yeah and I said
that article from was it the Athletic
Tribune mm-hmm I said nothing to her Sam
Muriel you come in all right okay
talking about being Gordon I send you
that article tonight yeah about his
mental health in like he was like
suicidal oh yeah yeah yeah so I said
that timmy is like I really like to
circle thanks for sending it to me and
they will talk about mental health I'm
like did you feel that did you have the
pressures of that when you were playing
basketball redlands and when you try it
out you know for the Knicks and all that
stuff and we got down into that so I
have these find these articles are
similar to the topics that we talk about
and be like dad read this article read
it so we could talk about it so that's
kind of our into it so he could
understand how I discern things and how
he can learn from me so I could learn
from him this is a brief concise [ __ ]
that's how he thinks or that's how he
does yeah that's hard man yeah cuz you
really want to know about his personal
[ __ ] right but then it's like you could
only get like a small little glimpse
yeah just by how he reads and interprets
things yeah it's like they'll be so
funny to you like you just send him this
film was like hey Dad watch this film
about this man who played basketball and
as it has a Vietnamese of Black Sun yeah
is like a kind of reminds me of you boy
yeah anyways yes I can know that I have
to like really you know fan it out for
him to like no this is if that were the
case like I was showing the vinegars
like this is our life yeah like let's
talk about it you know he probably would
you wouldn't maybe it like maybe he just
does that because he doesn't want to
feel all the [ __ ] that happened he just
kind of like pushes it all the way to
knocking down so a generation man a
certain certain age and all that [ __ ]
seeps out eventually you know my dad's
tough adult like it all came out and
that one huge moment where I literally
told him well you [ __ ] me up and he was
like at the end of that conversation I
think that the part that kind of really
softened me up he was like but actually
that's the first time I ever saw him cry
burned me he's never cried like I'm
talking about I've seen [ __ ] where he's
bald because my brother hurt his
feelings really and I've done some [ __ ]
by the edges like but the first time I
ever heard his feelings was that
conversation and then he just said like
I'm a good father like I did the best
that I could and he started tearing up
and I was like [ __ ] this guy's feelings
man
yeah such complex so complex and so
obtuse and just weird man man yeah it's
just it's it's kind of rough man I mean
we're gonna hopefully I won't be like
that when I'm older to [ __ ] I'm trying
not to be yeah I think that's like the
base level like I hope I don't turn out
crazy with my father and then I could
imagine my dad being like cuz there were
times when my dad would wait for his
father like hey I'm gonna pick you up
from the house to go fishing you know
dad's like you know cancelling plans
with his friends and he's just sitting
on this bench in front of his house out
in the middle of Victorville you just
kick it wash the Sun just go across the
horizon and his dad never shows up and
his mom comes his mom comes out it's
like come on boy it doesn't gonna come
that's a dude you know like he's like
I'm not gonna be my dad I'm never gonna
do what he did to me